i'm in ukraine
and like just about everybody leaving
kiev today
i spent about 10 hours so far in the car
and have gotten not that far away
[Music]
the roads are packed because the
civilian airspace has been closed
and there was real chaos at the main
rail station in kiev the bus service as
far as we had observed was also shut
down out of kiev and so
going by road fleeing by road west is
really the only way to go
many of the people i've been talking to
across ukraine can't even get out of the
cities they're in mainly because they
they're afraid to go outside they're
hearing small arms fire
missiles
all sorts of heavy
military action right around them
some of them feel like they can't leave
the gas stations locally have run out of
gas and they really don't know what to
do so the folks who are on this long
long drive
west out of kieva are really the lucky
ones
people who are fleeing the hostilities
are mostly going west and they're trying
to get over the borders
into moldova
slovakia hungary or poland
[Music]
you've seen people trying to get out in
all sorts of ways
we've passed
masses of people just simply trying to
hitchhike on the highway we've seen
people walking with
with luggage
people on bikes any which way they can
this is a lengthy process and then also
once they do get to the borders
depending on which country they're
they're trying to get into
the process of
getting through immigration there is is
adds many hours on top of that
it's too early to tell how this is all
going to go in terms of whether or not
we're looking at a prolonged refugee
crisis or if there's going to be
stability in kiev and other cities in
the near term that doesn't seem likely
foreign
you